[Musique]
droit fier et impassible même dans le
froid cinglant qui frappe la capitale au
poids des années s'ajoute celui de leurs
tristes souvenirs ceux qui restent
savent qu'ils ont le devoir d'honorer
ceux qui ne sont plus là où c'est
important quand deux marques toutes les
11 novembre
justement tous les sacrifices qui a été
fait pour nous au puy les sacrifices
qu'on va continuer à faire pour le
canada on pense aux collègues l'ex
sotrac assurent tous qu'ils font des
déploiements et puis c'est notre seule
chance de mériter souligné l'epa sens de
d'escrocs de profonds sentiments de
respect d'honneur de tristesse aussi qui
vont bien au delà de la grande famille
militaire c'est aujourd'hui si c'est
plus important que la faille du canada
c'est la libération on n'aurait rien
fait et le devoir de faire comprendre à
la nouvelle génération que sa paisible
existence a eu un prix important pour
qu'il vienne ici qui viennent expérience
et ça qu'ils viennent voir les vétérans
a menti quand nous qu'on les oublie pas
puis aussi il n'y a pas beaucoup de
grands vétérans la deuxième fois qu'il
est si pour vraiment remémorer les
anciens qui se sont battus avec respect
[Musique]
et l'espace de ce jour de novembre les
différents et la partisanerie sont mis
de côté pour moi c'est que le servent à
ce jour n'est que tous les canadiens et
n'importe quel groupe vous avez voté
pour avec l'élection s'en fout c'est
tout le monde est ensemble tout le monde
travaille ensemble on a gagné là dans la
première et la deuxième guerre mondiale
comme un pays ensemble
[Musique]
une dernière sonnerie
un ultime au revoir à l'unisson d'un
bout à l'autre du pays
et un seul message on leur doit un gros
gros merci
et aujourd'hui c'est la journée pour
leur dire je me souviens je vais m'en
souvenais toujours ici daniel thibault
radio canada à ottawa